lluvias récord nunca antes vistas así se
vieron afectados los residentes de
ciudades como colonia coblenza y renania
palatinado algunas de las más afectadas
por las lluvias e inundaciones en el
oeste de alemania- un hecho que ha
causado la peor pérdida de vidas en el
país en años dejando decenas de muertos
y desaparecidos algunos edificios
derribados cierre de carreteras y cortes
de luz desde eeuu la canciller angela
merkel que se encuentra en su último
viaje oficial a esta nación está
conmocionada por lo que describió como
una catástrofe en su dimensión son días
terribles para los habitantes de las
zonas inundadas mis pensamientos están
con ustedes y pueden confiar en que
todas las fuerzas de nuestro gobierno
federal regional y comunitario harán
colectivamente todo lo posible en las
condiciones más difíciles para salvar
vidas y mitigar los peligros y aliviar
la angustia que siente el fenómeno sin
precedentes los científicos coinciden en
que el cambio climático provocado por el
hombre es la principal razón
según los expertos de meteorología al
menos 158 litros de lluvia por metro
cuadrado cayeron en solo 24 horas las
más intensas desde que se llevan
registros en la región
las autoridades han declarado la
emergencia en las zonas afectadas
mientras continúan las labores de
rescate
en jets es natural y half of the land of
the lich ahora por supuesto también se
necesita ayuda del estado la cantidad de
ayuda aún no se puede cuantificar
financieramente porque no sabemos el
daño exacto ni alain en las zinc no
dejaremos solos a los municipios y a los
afectados brindaremos ayuda como estado
para canarias del norte westfalia se
mantenga unida en solidaridad en esta
situación según el servicio
meteorológico alemán se espera que las
lluvias intensas continúen hasta el
viernes